so
I'm Eric Jorgensen from the University
of Utah and today we have dr. Tom Reiss
and John Weiser and we're going to be
interviewing them and discussing some of
their seminal work that they did in the
1970s they were using an electron
microscope which you see in the
background this is a device that uses
electrons to image cells at a resolution
close to one nanometer so this is the
highest resolution microscope possible
and the 1970s they performed experiments
that allow us to understand
neurotransmission the fundamental
behavior of a cell during a
communication and they're going to tell
us about some of their experiments that
they performed them so what was the
experiment what was known what was not
known and what was the experiment and
what did it demonstrate we were
interested in a little structure of the
brain called the synapse and this saps
to me is about the most important
structure in the universe because it's a
way that nerve cells communicate with
each other and it's these networks of
communication they're allow us to think
and remember and and and be you know be
conscious and be who we are and so the
the synapse is sort of a rockstar of
biology because of its of its tremendous
interest and importance and I don't I've
been interested in synapse there was a
great deal already knowing about it it
was known about I worked electrically it
was known that it it released drugs
there but but nobody really had a
intimate understanding of how an actual
individual synapse works and that's what
we wanted you know and I was equally
interested and was graduating from
medical school and made a beeline for
the laboratory where the original work
had been done that set the stage where
electrophysiologists had demonstrated
that the communication of abandoned the
synapse involved the release of little
packages of chemical transmitter
little electrical blips that they could
see no man did that and whose lap I was
joining Sir Bernard Katz went on to get
the Nobel Prize after that but his
insight was profound and on top of that
he'd written unbelievably beautiful
papers that terribly impressed me as a
student so made a beeline for that lab
he had already looked at electron
micrographs and seen the the synapses
and the inside were filled with tiny
membranous membrane vesicles little
spheres of membrane and he made the
brilliant but logical interpretation
that those little spheres contained the
packages of transmitter that he was
measuring electrically as little blips
and so he had the insight to propose
that the little electrical blips were
being generated by chemicals coming from
those tiny packages that was established
I mean it was such a clear-cut idea that
it almost had to be that way and so my
project when I entered that lab as a
postdoc in those days you're basically
assigned to project was to quote proven
get an image of these little vesicles
popping on the surface of the nerve when
I stimulate the mirror and during that
postdoc I didn't get it but I had the
opportunity to join Tom Maurice at the
NIH immediately after that weari
formulated the problem came up with a
whole new approach to proving or
disproving that idea that cat's a head
so Tom maybe you could tell us how it
came to be that you met John and how
that led to a collaboration and John
came to the lab we decide to try a hold
of her approach he's John point I
usually went to allows a postdoc and
they're assigned a project but in this
case he came to the lab assignment
project which was he'll work on this
thing so we originally were thinking
about looking at the aftermath and
trying to interpret back to what might
have happened
that'll you that was a good approach as
it turned out yes they have been the
idea if if these little packages are
opening to discharge transmitter and
that's the mechanism communication then
during that moment of opening they
should be able to capture a material
from outside the cell and carry it back
in and it would be an indirect proof
that at least they have interacted with
the surface so what you demonstrated was
that the membrane the synaptic vesicles
were normally found in this in the
synapse and the bouton and that they had
visited the surface and that's all you
could show and the problem was a
question of time scale or was there
something missing um there was the
missing fact that we have nothing but
embalming fluid and we were dropping
these things in embalming fluid every
time and life did not continue in any
kind of appropriate manner in that
solution so we didn't capture it but a
missing piece here the next step of any
rate was when we decided well while we
just stimulate the nerve for various
grades of time and then and then fix it
immediately or let it sit for a while on
they look so we did a series of
different time and different routes of
stimulation and different time intervals
full recovery and that turned out to be
very informative because when you
stimulated the nerve to the nerve ending
over the vesicles were I've got quite a
bit bigger as if the vesicles and sod
were being added to the surface and so
that was a second there's a second piece
of evidence and then and then if you if
you wait a while after you stimulated
before he fixed he went back to probably
mama looking worthy of normal looking
terminal as if there was a cycle of
activity and recovery and Anton that
cycle knowing the cycle involved some
into the vesicle compartment and I have
to say John it's all he didn't burn
through me but the idea of vesicle
recycling was totally yours okay
what no really I mean I at the time I
was a still I was astonished by this
idea because they'd never know it
occurred to me I'm done oh I'll take
some credit later for some other selves
okay it's true that the very first paper
we wrote on the attempts in London to
get it to work for we didn't but we got
this aftermath effect we said maybe the
vesicles are dissolving and being
reformed or we sure had a very happy I
don't I said or maybe it's merely
recycling merely recycling is the final
sentence of my paper in London merely it
became our career to pin that down and
work it out so so back in 1973 one were
these when you publish this was this
except that at that point what were
there anybody was there anybody else who
was doing these experiments at the time
oh yeah tell me a little bit about what
was going on in 1973 when this paper
came out 73 there was a whole cadre of
people doing this kind of work all
fascinated by the nervous system all
having electron microscopy as the tool
they've become experts at it that was
really the heyday of electron microscopy
was the opportunity to see things for
the first time at that resolution
so everything was a gold mine and
everything was fascinating and exciting
people were going crazy so there were a
number of people that have your
neurobiologist - also focused on the
nerve terminal and the remarkable thing
is that two or three groups including
groups here at the marine biology labs
and Europe particularly in Milan were
focusing on the exact same preparation
with us and doing the exact same
experiments and we were publishing him
the exact same journals pictures that
could have been swapped from one paper
to the other and isn't it in human
nature they were drawing completely
different conclusions
about how to interpret those micrographs
so there has never been peace in this
field there's never been consensus and
we are still to this day battling out
the interpretation of what you see in an
electron micrograph but the way we were
thinking was indicative of the way it's
always been
we were were why we left everybody in
the dust right then was because we're
saying how do you see it how are we
gonna see that yeah what we do those we
do they have we put it on that substrate
we look at it with this instrument that
etc we'd moved instantly into the
technology of it yeah yeah we're always
getting the right image period but you
can't forget that the rationale for
doing it at all from working and
developing this machine was basically to
capture this event of neurotransmission
and the physiologist had taught us that
the event occurs one thousandth of a
second when activity spreads into a
nerve and the members gonna communicate
with the next one by secreting these
little chemicals from synaptic vesicles
it takes only one one thousandth of a
second for it to happen and we needed to
capture that event on that same time
scale we need to capture it and it's all
forever
so that was why we went to all the
effort to develop the freezing machine
further so maybe John you could describe
the instrument for our viewers so in all
of its glory and complications oh well I
wish it were glorious and complicated
but it couldn't be more trivial it's a
copper block copper chosen because it's
a very highly conductive metal the most
highly conductive reticulate those
temperatures so you have a heat sink the
best heat sink you can think of imagine
and you want to apply it the thing you
want to study in the electron microscope
in our case these little nerve terminals
doing their secretory event won't apply
it to it to the that prep to the copper
block is abruptly and precisely timed as
possible so we just flame plugged it
down on top of
just bumped it into it touched it to the
surface to the copper surface of four
degrees Kelvin to hook up all
stimulating electrodes and developed
methods of synchronizing that event and
how was that done how did you time when
you would stimulate before it hit the
copper block simply had a magnet mounted
right next to the sample which could be
used to buy a little sensor that senses
magnets as the magnet passed the sensor
said you're about to hit the copper
block and that stimulated the electrode
that fired the action potential nerve so
we could synchronize that action
potential arrived the vesicles
discharged and the sample hit the drop
the block in a thousandth of a second
but you also had a problem with the
sample freezing before it ever hit the
song after it got so close to the copper
that have pre froze before it would get
stimulated but the real trick was and
still is and you need to use it oh the
drug the drug that augmented release our
physiology friends who helped us work on
it said either between a thousand or ten
thousand times one marathon pulse would
release ten thousand times more vesicles
than normal if you make a nerve
stimulate temp of release ten thousand
times more than normal it isn't going to
want to do that very often it doesn't
once young it's shot so we have to make
sure we don't pre stimulated as we're
getting the whole experiment ready so
you do the experiment what do you see
was there a Eureka moment where you were
on the scope and you said oh my god this
is it we can hope we see the light this
is the image we're looking for me can
you describe a little bit about that
were you together where did it happen
as it happened Tom wasn't there at the
particular time that happened he was
back in and I actually happened in San
Francisco but at that time I had Mike
Dennis was a very fine physiologist who
was doing all this treatment with his
magical drug that increased things so
much and we had too young even predock's
either maybe they had just gotten their
postdoc and
wanted to learn Samia so they were
wandering around my lab so we're getting
in the way underfoot but one of them
Lily Jiang and her husband you know jail
who was the other person wandering
around both have gone on to great
careers but they so they're sitting on
the microscope and they called me into
the microscope and they said John I
think we've got it I mean look at that
and I came in and looked over their
shoulder and I said no no that's a
capillary you don't recognize you know
there were a bunch of little vesicles
attached to the surface of the capillary
all the time that's part of transport of
blood nothing to do with nerves you
forget it looked a little harder my god
it is a nerve terminal look at all those
openings and that really wasn't Eureka
moment what was it you saw what was it
that you're actually looking for that
was that Eureka
Tom had explained that we're at that
point we're doing it by freeze fracture
it's a method of looking at the surface
membrane of the nerve by cracking open
this frozen tissue particularly nice
because after all we'd started by
freezing it so why not take advantage of
it the technique so we're cracking all
these nerves open it's a tube so here's
a long cylinder and on that cylinder
dotting all the way down are these small
craters like craters on the moon and
it's a very small jump to remember
vesicles were originally lined up on
this membrane inside inside and you
couldn't see it from the outside you
wouldn't have seen it at all in Seminole
and so the fact that now you could see
though it's the openings it meant that
they'd actually explore it open under
the surface of the just just right
before they the muscle hit that copper
block and frozen so we captured captured
them in a millisecond time scale which
is I don't think anybody really did die
Anatomy structures of things on that
time scale there was a nice story of
merge right after that and that is after
that NASA golden we noticed that that in
the wall and the membrane and the best
of all there were various kinds of
struck
and that as time got he see it would
with this reading we do highlights
memory it stimulated a 10 millisecond 20
million 30 miles there so we know a time
past that the vesicle was getting wider
and wider open and that some of these
particles inside these structures inside
were coming out and diffusing into the
service membrane and so that was not a
story I we measured all out and made a
story I made a story out of that and so
that was that was the third leg that was
actually I enjoyed that actually that
part of it well it's a critical piece of
the puzzle because if you have these
little packages of transmitter and
they're capable of fusing with the
surface in a thousandth of a second
activating by calcium what happens to
them after that and why were we seeing
all these strange changes at much longer
times well that's when we really have
fun with the freezing machine we were no
longer just trying to capture the
immediate moment but the aftermath of
the event as Tom described it we can now
do aftermath and really close
coordination we can be looking just
milliseconds later and it's our
conviction that it's in the nature of
tiny membranous vesicle something about
biophysics of membranes that when that
joins the larger membrane like the
surface of the nerve terminal it has no
alternative but it has to collecting it
has to flatten out join that membrane
completely and therefore deposit all of
its contents and its own nature this in
the debate so you showed the best ball
touches flattens out and I mean
basically it's irreversible absolutely
in the debate Eric you're baiting us
because you know perfectly well that the
our colleagues in Italy our colleagues
at the MDL and son did not accept the
sieves ayodhya sticking out at this
point yeah they might have they had to
accept that cat's was fundamentally
right but that's how neural transmission
occurs
fusion of these bicycles but then is
when interpretation of electron
micrographs and interpretation of how
you did the experiment because they
looked at the same micrographs
vesicle fused with the cell surface and
concluded that that was it that that
vesicle did that transiently a little
kiss kissed the surface let out
transmitter and simply reversed the
process now I was earlier describing to
you that we thought it's in the
biophysics of membranes that they can't
do that that if they've joined a mother
bigger guy they're going to merge with
it completely and so there is a
controversy that is embedded in the
literature and scientific thinking to
today and everyone asks about that still
are you really correct that all of your
aftermath stuff is really true or should
we believe the Italian group that it's
just a kiss the vesicles are kissing and
coming right back in again in the exact
momentary exposure and then closure
that's the PI of the true binding
physics and so we don't know then did
experiments that were over longer and
longer periods of time and then you saw
something that said well there is
evidence that in fact these vesicles are
collapsing fully into the map yes
aftermath experiments with everything
we're seeing eight milliseconds
particles inside the host when I'm ready
yes
it's fusing diffusing particles being
our marker membrane and not all
particles are places where the membrane
is impinged by a transmembrane protein
and then free structure does show up as
bumps and the bumps the bumps were they
were defusing out of the vesicle
membrane into the whole other membrane
no it's not going to do that kiss and
run what is it the you know you saw in
your images that convinced you that
vesicles had to be recycled yeah well
the reason I would have had a
preliminary that I had a preliminary
glimpse of that and said that maybe
merely recycling happened was because of
the magic clathrin-coated vesicles that
appeared in the nerve
terminal as a consequence of stimulation
and I had just come from my
undergraduate work where I was exposed
to the father of electron microscopy
Keith Porter and his one of the yeah
trained so many outstanding people but a
person who was still present when I was
in college was Tom Roth and he had just
discovered that the mechanism of
endocytosis the mechanism of uptake of
material from the outside world in all
cells is mediated by a vesicle that has
a quote beautiful cytoplasmic coat that
actually is polygamous like Buckminster
Fuller geodetic dome and you can see
that dole in the electron microscope and
so here I'm the young guy in London and
I see these domes in nerve terminals as
a consequence of stimulation you've seen
I was in London yeah I said oh my god
it's endocytosis and then it's also
interesting that we managed to end your
total contentious situation with our
Italian competitors over that because
they couldn't see these coated vesicles
and why couldn't they see it and we did
well it was simply that technique of
embalming we used ours was a little bit
different than bears aureus had a little
bit more heavy metal than it than theirs
so the coats looked a little more
dramatic and our pictures than in bears
but that's the way that electron
microscopy was count but horns and can
endure total disagreement total
contentiousness it's not an issue in the
end what I think solved the debate are
those freeze images where you see the
clathrin coat this is absolutely clear
that geodesic structure is absolutely
clear maybe you could tell us a little
bit about the invention of the freeze
edge technique and how you use that to
show that there were clathrin-coated
vesicles that was a late chapter that
arose from being able to directly freeze
things because if you freeze things out
in their natural juice when you try to
draw the water away the condoms the
juices
collapse down top or anything you can't
see anything so something we were able
to to freeze but any will freeze
directly died because I fix it which
also distort things we had a whole world
looking at the inside of membranes and
that was invented in our summer biology
of summer neurobiology person would slow
like one of John's students made a
mistake on the machine and John decided
to have a look at anyway and that was
one of those Eureka moments all of a
sudden the first time we could actually
look inside inside the cytoplasm not
just look at the membranes like you do
with free structure but even look inside
the cytoplasm and you could see all the
CDs wonderful quotes and John and when
I'm back to San Francisco and began a
decade marvelous work looking at that
that's the bonus for those who cycle I
think that's a good place to end it but
before we do I would like to ask whether
you guys have anything that reflections
or memories or anything else you'd like
to add thank you for doing my friend the
boys version it's been sprite about
feeling differences we've gotten down
that's what I didn't say exactly the
same thing yep thank you for being my
friend and news and colleague it's just
you